[S01] 当你打开手机啊，刷着几千万粉丝大V的最新动态时，你可能以为
[S01] Twitter 的后台正在为你疯狂地拼凑文字和图片，再把它们一股脑推送到你的屏幕上。
[S02] 这个是一个非常普遍的直觉。
[S01] 对吧？但真相其实相当反直觉。Twitter 在为你准备的缓存里，根本就没有存这些帖子的内容，它存的仅仅是一串干巴巴的数字 ID。
[S01] 欢迎你加入今天的深度解析。
[S02] 很高兴能和大家一起探讨。
[S01] 今天我们要彻底打破一个固有印象。我们总觉得呃编写软件就是敲击一堆枯燥的代码和冷冰冰的逻辑。
[S01] 但实际上你选择如何存储数据，正在潜移默化地重塑你的大脑。
[S02] 没错，这其实是技术世界里最令人着迷的地方。
[S01] 今天我们要聚焦的是被无数工程师奉为圭臬的经典著作，也就是大家常说的DDIA——《设计数据密集型应用》。我们要深挖它第三章关于数据模型与查询语言的探讨。
[S02] 这是一章非常硬核，但也极其具有启发性的内容。
[S01] 书里引用了哲学家维特根斯坦的一句名言，语言的边界就是世界的边界。这句话就是我们今天这场解析的任务设定，不是一堂枯燥的数据库基础课。我们要带你探索数据模型如何不仅决定了软件的架构，更深刻地决定了我们如何去思考问题。
[S02] 如果你仔细观察任何一个复杂的应用程序，你会发现它其实是由一层又一层的数据模型堆叠而成的。每一层的核心使命只有一个，那就是向上一层隐藏底层的复杂性。
[S01] 就像套娃一样的吧。
[S02] 完全正确。
[S02] 作为开发者，你看到的是现实世界里的人、订单、货物、资金流动。然后你把它们抽象成代码里的呃对象。
[S01] 嗯，面向对象编程嘛。
[S02] 对，当你需要存储时，你又要把这些对象转换成JSON 文档，或者是关系型的表格。
[S01] 到了数据库工程师呢？
[S02] 哎，他们就要把这些表格转换成内存或磁盘上的字节连续体。最终硬件层再把这些字节变成了微小的电信号，每一层都在为你提供一个简洁的幻觉。
[S01] 所以今天我们要做的就是撕开这种幻觉，去看看为了维持这些幻觉，我们在不同的数据模型之间究竟做出了哪些极其艰难的取舍。
[S02] 没错。
[S01] 既然我们要探讨取舍，那必须从大家最熟悉的老朋友说起，也就是呃统治了数据世界半个世纪的关系型数据库SQL。
[S02] 老大哥级别的存在。
[S01] 是的，绝大多数现代应用都是用面向对象的编程语言写的，但在底层数据却被塞进了基于关系代数的二维表格里。这感觉就好比你想打一个立体的魔方，硬塞进一个扁平的信封里，
[S01] 中间不可避免地会产生巨大的摩擦。
[S02] 在工程界，这场摩擦有一个非常专业的名词叫做对象关系阻抗不匹配。
[S01] 阻抗不匹配，这听起来像是个物理词汇。
[S02] 呃，它本来确实是用在电子学里的，指两个电路连接时，如果阻抗不一致，信号传输就会受阻。
[S02] 在软件开发中也是一样的道理。
[S01] 所以我们就搞出了个中间件。
[S02] 对，为了把面向对象的代码存进二维表格，我们需要在应用程序和数据之间硬生生地插入一个笨拙的转换层，也就是ORM 对象关系映射。
[S01] 好的，
[S01] 让我们来拆解一下这个概念。
[S01] ORM就像是一个勉强及格的翻译软件，你让它在代码里去买一份夫妻肺片，结果它给底层的数据库，他可能真的会去屠宰场呃，给你找两个人出来。这种思维模式上的不匹配，往往就是性能灾难的根源。
[S02] 这个比喻非常精准，ORM 框架确实帮开发者省去了大量手写重复代码的麻烦。
[S01] 确实省事。
[S02] 但它并不能完全隐藏两种思维模型之间的巨大鸿沟。最臭名昭著的例子就是N+1查询问题。
[S01] 啊，N+1，无数程序员的噩梦，你能给听众简单解释一下吗？
[S02] 没问题。
[S02] 假设你要在一个页面上展示一个包含N条评论的列表，最直观的做法是去数据库把这N条评论拿出来。
[S01] 这没毛病啊。
[S02] 但是评论表里通常只存了作者的 ID。为了在网页上显示作者的名字和头像，ORM可能会针对着N条评论，在后台悄悄就发起了N 次单独的查询，去获取每一个作者的信息。
[S01] 天呐，也就是一条评论查一次。
[S02] 是的，结果就是为了展示一个列表，你总共发起了N+1次查询。如果你手写 SQL，这其实只需要一个简单的 JOIN，也就是连接操作，就能一次性搞定。
[S01] 效率差了成百上千倍。
[S02] 对，但在ORM的掩护下，
[S02] 开发者极容易在不知不觉中就把数据库的连接池给耗尽了。
[S01] 这确实让人头疼。这个时候文档模型，也就是我们常说的NoSQL 或者JSON，就像是带着降维打击的姿态出现了。你想想看，我们平时在LinkedIn 上看到的个人简历，
[S02] 那是一个非常典型的文档场景。
[S01] 在传统的关系型数据库里，因为一个人有多份工作经历，多段教育背景，你必须把这个人的信息无情地拆碎。
[S02] 对，分成多张表。
[S01] 分散存储在职位表、教育经历表等好几个表里，然后用外键连接起来。这就好比把一辆汽车拆成零件，分别存在不同的仓库里，每次要用还得重新组装。
[S02] 但在JSON 文档模型中，这是一种天然的树状结构，用户所有的职位、教育经历都可以作为数组，
[S02] 直接嵌套在这个用户自己的JSON 文档里。
[S01] 都在一个文件里。
[S02] 是的，这在数据库领域被称为数据局部性。当你需要展示这个用户的简历时，你根本不需要去多个仓库里到处寻找零件。
[S01] 一次查询就全搞定了。
[S02] 没错，所有相关信息直接作为一个完整的包裹被提取出来。不管是查询速度还是代码的直观程度，都完美契合了开发者的心智模型。
[S01] 既然JSON 文档这么方便，感觉就像是一个打包好的万能快递盒。那我有个疑问，为什么我们不干脆把所有的数据都塞进JSON 里呢？
[S02] 比如呢？
[S01] 比如把用户所在的城市和国家也作为纯文本，直接写进这个简历文档里，不要什么地区表了，查询起来不是更快吗？
[S02] 呃，这就引出了一个数据建模的终极权衡。如何处理共享数据的连通性？
[S01] 怎么讲？
[S02] 如果你的简历里直接写了纯文本的华盛顿特区，短期内确实没问题，
[S02] 读取速度飞快。
[S01] 对啊，
[S01] 省得去join其他表了。
[S02] 但你想想，如果华盛顿特区改名了呢，或者你的网站要上线多语言版本，要把所有的华盛顿特区统统翻译成法文，你该怎么办？
[S01] 哇，那我岂不是得把所有用户的文档全翻一遍？
[S02] 没错，你必须去遍历几千万个用户的JSON 文档，找到每一个纯文本并修改它。这在工程上几乎是一个不可能完成的任务，不仅慢，
[S02] 而且极容易出错。
[S01] 所以更聪明的做法是从一个标准化的列表里选择，然后数据库里只存一个呃地区 ID。
[S02] 完全正确。
[S01] 这就回到了我们常说的规范化，也就是消除冗余有意义的信息只存储一份，其他所有地方都通过ID来引用它。只要改了主表里的名字，所有引用这个ID的地方都会自动更新。
[S02] 是的，但你要知道，规范化的代价是，当你取得数据时，必须把这个ID还原成人类可读的文字。
[S01] 也就是必须做join。
[S02] 对，这就需要执行join操作。
[S02] 问题是，
[S02] 传统的文档数据库在设计之初，
[S02] 对join的支持通常是非常弱的。
[S01] 甚至有些根本不支持。
[S02] 没错，这就产生了一个有趣的对比。文档模型通常被称为读时模式，而关系型数据库是写时模式。
[S01] 读时模式。但很多人不是说文档数据库是无模式，也就是schemaless吗？
[S02] 那个词其实是个误导。当你取得JSON时，你的代码里总是预设了某种结构的，它更像编程语言里的动态类型。你想加一个新字段，直接写进去就行。
[S01] 嗯，非常灵活。
[S02] 而关系型数据库就像静态类型，你要修改表结构，必须先执行严格的迁移指令。
[S01] 了解了这些，这里才是真正有趣的地方。我们再回头看开头提到的推特，也就是现在的 X，它的例子就会发现大规模系统中的取舍有多么魔幻。
[S02] 推特的时间线架构是教科书级别的。
[S01] 当千万粉丝的大V发了一条推文，为了让所有人能瞬间看到推特在后台会进行一个扇出操作。
[S02] 所谓的扇出，也就是 fan-out。你可以想象成在现实世界里发传单，
[S01] 大V按下了发送键，后台系统就会像扇子打开一样，把这条推文的引用复制成千万份，疯狂地塞进他每一个粉丝的时间线缓存收件箱里。
[S02] 这其实是一种高度反规范化的操作，对吧？目的是为了让你打开APP的瞬间就能看到内容，而不需要临时去遍历你关注的所有人。
[S01] 是的，极致的读性能优化。
[S02] 但最绝的地方在于，就像我们开头说的，
[S02] 这个传单上印的根本不是推文内容，而只是一串 ID。我当时就想，既然已经做了耗费资源的扇出缓存，为什么不干脆把文字内容也一起缓存进去呢？这不就彻底省事了吗？
[S01] 因为我们要考虑数据变化的频率。
[S02] 频率。你想想帖子的点赞数、转发数，或者是大V换了头像，这些数据每秒都在疯狂跳动。
[S01] 对，数字一直在这跳。
[S02] 如果你把这些信息直接写死在每个粉丝的缓存里，大V的一个帖子被点赞一次，你就得去更新几千万个粉丝的缓存。
[S01] 哇，
[S01] 那系统瞬间就崩溃了。
[S02] 绝对会。所以架构师做出了极其精妙的妥协。对于关注关系，这种相对稳定的结构进行反规范化缓存。但对于点赞数、文本内容，这些高频变化的数据，
[S02] 系统只存 ID。
[S01] 那用户怎么看到完整的帖子呢？
[S02] 当你滑动屏幕时，手机上的应用层会拿着这串 ID去数据库里实时获取最新的点赞数和内容。这个过程在工程上被称为hydrating，也就是数据填充。
[S01] 这简直打破了大家的刻板印象。因为很多初级程序员都被教导说，千万别在应用层做join,性能会很差。
[S02] 但推特恰恰证明了，只要你的架构设计得当，
[S02] 应用层join反而能解决底层数据库无法承受的高频更新问题。
[S01] 确实是大开眼界。不过如果说推特只是在帖子和用户之间做了一层简单的join,那如果我们的数据里全都是错综复杂的网状关系呢？
[S02] 比如什么样的场景？
[S01] 比如你要找你朋友的朋友中，有哪些人也在同一家公司工作，并且也喜欢某款游戏，这就引出了我们的下一个维度，图数据模型。
[S02] 当数据之间的关系变得比数据本身更重要时，图数据库就该登场了。
[S02] 在图模型里，世界是由顶点，也就是实体和边，也就是关系组成的。
[S01] 就像一张大网。
[S02] 没错，社交图谱、网页、路由，甚至是欺诈检测网络，
[S02] 都是典型的图数据。
[S01] 让我们用一个具体的例子来看看图数据到底有多强大。假设有个人叫Lucy，他出生在美国的爱达荷州。
[S02] 爱达荷州属于美国。
[S01] 对，另一个人叫Alain,出生在法国，他们结婚了，并且目前住在伦敦，而伦敦属于欧洲。这些信息在图数据里就是一堆带箭头的连线。现在如果我们想向图数据提问，
[S01] 找出所有从美国移民到欧洲的人，你会怎么查？
[S02] 呃，如果在关系型数据库的SQL里查，这几乎是一场噩梦。
[S01] 为什么？
[S01] SQL不是很强大吗？
[S02] 你必须使用一种叫做递归公用表表达式的高级语法。
[S01] 听起来就很复杂。
[S02] 你得写整整三十一行极其笨拙、难以阅读的代码，
[S02] 才能勉强把这些层级遍历完。
[S01] 三十一行。但如果你使用的是专门为图数据库设计的查询语言，比如Cypher,你知道需要几行吗？
[S02] Cypher确实非常简洁。
[S01] 只需要短短四行代码，你可以用非常直观的文字符号，比如用横线和箭头来代表关系，甚至可以用一个星号直接告诉数据库，
[S01] 帮我穿越任意层级的区域包含关系，不管中间隔了多少个城市和州。
[S02] 这完全是对SQL的降维打击。
[S01] 简直就是秒杀。
[S02] 这就是专用查询语言的魅力。除了Cypher,业界其实还有一种基于古老的逻辑编程语言Prolog发展而来的语言，叫做DataLog。
[S01] DataLog这个词感觉很有年代感。
[S02] 确实很古老，但它非常强大。它不是用SELECT去一步一步查找数据，
[S02] 而是通过定义一系列的规则来推导事实。
[S01] 怎么推导？
[S02] 比如你定义一条规则，如果城市在州内，州在国家内，
[S02] 那么城市就在国家内。通过这种递归推导，它可以非常优雅地解决极其复杂的网络问题。
[S01] 等等。说到图网络，现在前端开发界非常流行，
[S01] 一个叫GraphQL 的技术，
[S01] 它名字里就带着GRAPH,也就是图。但你先前说它为了安全，反而刻意在规范里限制了图最擅长的递归查询能力。
[S02] 是的，这是一个非常核心的工程妥协。
[S01] 这就像买了一辆法拉利跑车，厂商却在引擎里焊死了一个限速器，不让你挂最高档啊，这到底是为什么？
[S02] 它涉及到拒绝服务攻击，也就是 DoS 的防范机制。我们要知道，图查询的层级一旦不确定是非常危险的。
[S01] 为什么危险？
[S02] 如果一个恶意的黑客利用GraphQL 发出了一个请求，要求查找朋友的朋友的朋友的朋友的朋友的朋友的朋友的朋友的朋友，连续念到十层。
[S02] 对，在前端看来，这是一行简短的代码，但底层的图数据库为了遍历这张无底洞一样的巨大关系网，会瞬间耗尽所有的内存和CPU 资源，导致整个服务器直接宕机。
[S01] 所以不得不加上限速器。
[S02] 因为GraphQL 的核心诉求是方便手机端 UI按需获取数据，它是直接暴露给不可信的公共网络的。所以牺牲一部分查询能力，换取系统的绝对安全是必须付出的代价。
[S01] 原来如此，为了防止被一句简短的代码挤爆内存，只能做出这种安全妥协。
[S01] 好，
[S01] 我们刚才聊了关系型表格，
[S01] JSON 文档，还有错综复杂的图网络。但这些模型都有一个共同点，
[S02] 它们描绘的都是世界的当前状态。
[S01] 没错，就像你拍了一张照片，记录了这一瞬间。但是如果你想知道这个状态是怎么来的呢？这就引出了数据模型中一个极其有趣的分支事件溯源，也就是Event Sourcing。
[S02] 这可能是今天最颠覆直觉的一个概念了。
[S01] 是吗？
[S02] 你想象一下，你的银行账户，
[S02] 银行底层绝对不可能只在数据库里存一个当前余额一千元的数字。
[S01] 那肯定不行，钱怎么没的都不知道。
[S02] 如果你存了一百块，又取了五十块，底层的核心其实是一笔笔不可改变的交易流水。事件溯源也是同样的逻辑。
[S01] 也就是不存结果，只存过程。
[S02] 对，
[S02] 我们不再直接更新数据库里的当前状态，
[S02] 而是把数据的变化表示为一个绝对不可变的追加日志。而且因为它们代表已经发生的历史事件的命名，必须使用过去时态。比如座位已预定，预定已取消。
[S01] 假设我们有一个会议室管理系统，如果你只是维护一个当前可用座位数的字段，面对复杂的退订、房间容量调整，只要代码稍微出点BUG,座位数就全乱套了，你根本查不出是哪一步算错了。
[S02] 但如果你记录的是所有历史事件的日志呢？
[S01] 那我就可以随时根据这些不可变的日志，从头推导出我需要的任何结果。这个被推导出来的当前状态在数据库里被称为呃物化视图。
[S02] 是的，Materialized View这种架构的优势是令人难以抗拒的。首先意图极其清晰，它自带完美的审计日志。
[S01] 谁在什么时间干了什么，清清楚楚。
[S02] 更重要的是，它是绝对可复现的。如果某天你发现你的物化视图统计代码写错了，导致座位数显示不对，你完全不需要慌张。
[S01] 直接删掉重来。
[S02] 对，你只需要把那个视图直接删掉，用修改后的正确代码，把历史事件日志重新跑一遍，
[S02] 一切就完美修复了。
[S01] 哇，这个听起来像魔法一样完美，但我必须提出一个现实的挑战。
[S02] 你说。
[S01] 如果事件是绝对不可变的，只追加的日志。
[S01] 那如果遇到GDPR,也就是通用数据保护条例，
[S01] 要求彻底删除某用户的个人隐私数据怎么办？既然不能修改历史记录，这在现实中难道不是个巨大的合规噩梦吗？
[S02] 这是一个非常敏锐，也非常犀利的质疑。技术上的完美，往往需要向现实世界的规则低头。
[S01] 那业界是怎么解决这个矛盾的？
[S02] 面对不可变日志与隐私删除权之间的矛盾，业界有一种非常聪明的妥协方案，叫做加密粉碎。
[S01] 加密粉碎 crypto-shredding 听起来像是在赛博空间里用碎纸机。
[S02] 机制其实很巧妙。当你把用户的敏感个人数据写入不可变的事件日志时，你先用一个独立的密钥对这段数据进行加密。
[S01] 所以日志里存的其实是一段密文。
[S02] 没错，
[S02] 当用户行使被遗忘权要求彻底删除时，你根本不需要去破坏那些不可变的历史日志。
[S01] 那怎么删？
[S02] 你只需要在密钥管理系统里，把那个用来解密的密钥彻底销毁。
[S01] 哇，这就够了吗？
[S02] 密钥一毁，日志里的那段密文就永远变成了一堆无法解读的数学噪音。
[S02] 从合规的角度看，
[S02] 这就等同于数据被彻底删除了。
[S01] 这招真是太巧妙了，既维持了底层架构的纯洁性，
[S01] 又解决了现实的合规难题。
[S01] 那么我们刚才聊的这些，无论关系型、JSON、图还是事件流，
[S01] 其实都是在处理具体的业务流程，也就是 OLTP。
[S02] Online Transaction Processing.
[S01] 但是如果坐在屏幕前收听我们解析的是一位数据科学家呢，他想要把海量数据丢进AI 大模型里进行训练，
[S01] 之前的这些模型还能奏效吗？
[S02] 到了数据科学和Machine Learning的领域，我们就需要彻底切换思维方式了。
[S01] 怎么切换？
[S02] AI的neural network或者Machine Learning算法是不懂什么是JSON tree或者graph network的。
[S01] 他们只认识数字。
[S02] 他们只认识纯粹的数学矩阵，这就引入了数据框，也就是DataFrames.比如大家常用的pandas 或者 Spark以及矩阵模型。
[S01] 我们来想象一个经典的场景。
[S01] 你有一个巨大的关系型表格，记录了一千万个用户对十万部电影的评分。
[S01] 在进行机器学习之前，你需要把这个表格转换成一个庞大的矩阵。
[S02] 也就是所谓的特征矩阵。
[S01] 矩阵的每一行代表一个用户，
[S01] 每一列代表一部电影，
[S01] 中间的交叉点就是评分。但你想想，绝大部分人一辈子也看不了几百部电影，所以这个矩阵里百分之九十九的格子都是空白的，这就是所谓的稀疏矩阵。
[S02] 没错，在内存里高效地处理和运算，这种稀疏矩阵是科学计算的核心。但这又带来了一个新问题。
[S01] 什么问题？
[S02] 评分是数字矩阵可以处理，但如果电影的属性是文本呢？
[S01] 比如类别是喜剧或者恐怖。
[S02] 对，线性代数的公式里是不能带有喜剧这两个汉字的。
[S01] 这就到了数据科学家最常用的魔法。呃，
[S01] 独热编码出场的时候了。One-Hot Encoding
[S02] 独热编码。
[S02] 简单来说就是把文本分类彻底降维成二进制数字。
[S01] 能具体解释一下吗？
[S02] 它会把电影类别这一个文本字段横向展开成多个独立的列。
[S01] 哦，我懂了。
[S02] 有一列叫是否是喜剧，
[S02] 有一列叫是否是恐怖。如果是喜剧片，
[S02] 那么喜剧那一列的值就是一，其他所有类别列的值都是零。
[S01] 哇，非常直接。通过这种物理形态上的转换，所有复杂的业务属性都被剥离了外衣，变成了纯粹的零一以及浮点数据矩阵。
[S01] 只有这样，数据才能真正准备好去接受底层算法和张量运算的洗礼。
[S02] 完全剥离了业务属性，只剩下纯粹的数学。
[S01] 那么这一切到底意味着什么呢？
[S01] 我们今天走过了一段漫长且极其丰富的旅程，从关系型表格的严谨结构，到JSON 文档的灵活自由，从图数据库里错综复杂的深度连接，到事件溯源里那不可磨灭的历史记忆。
[S02] 最后还感受了矩阵和数据框剥离业务属性后的数学之美。
[S01] 是的，作为一名持续学习者，你可能在日常工作中并不会亲自去写每一种查询语言的底层代码。但需要知道的是，在面对不同的现实业务场景时，你应该能够自如地带上不同的思维滤镜，去重新审视你的数据。
[S02] 如果我们把这个和宏观图景联系起来看，
[S02] 你会发现一个非常奇妙的趋势。
[S02] 天下大事，分久必合。
[S01] 数据模型也在融合。
[S02] 对，各大数据库正在走向大融合。老牌的关系型数据库，比如PostgreSQL 纷纷开始原生支持 JSON 字段，甚至加了图查询插件。而曾经标榜无模式，只追求速度的文档数据库，也默默加上了对 JOIN 和ACID 事务的支持。
[S01] 不同数据模型之间的边界正在变得越来越模糊。
[S02] 确实如此。
[S01] 这就给屏幕前的你留下了一个非常引人深思的悬念。既然各大数据库厂商都在拼命把所有的功能，所有的模型融合到一个超级系统里，这究竟意味着我们将迎来一个能完美理解万物互联的终极数据库。
[S02] 这是一条可能的路。
[S01] 还是说我们只是在不断堆砌抽象层，直到有一天这个系统变得如此复杂，以至于在这个星球上再也没有任何一个人类工程师能够完全理解它底层的运行逻辑了。
[S02] 细思可恐，但非常现实。
[S01] 下次当你写下一句简单的查询代码时，不妨想一想这个问题，感谢你加入今天的深度解析，期待我们下次在一起探索更多的硬核知识。
[S01] 再见。
[S02] 再见。